what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to she
assaulted
myron gaines um nina unrated before i
start do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos
um
can you guys see my face okay um follow
my instagram while you're at it it's
just pearly things but with the z
um that's at the end you change that to
a z and then it's just pearly banks
trey with the mics 50k tray man
we got to say i don't know if you're 50k
man you already subscribers man
we out here okay so you got mine games
here in the building what's up guys
so behind the scenes oh we got nina here
vlogging as well
hey shout out to her within a vlog
a vlog section that's what you call it
vlog interception so yeah we out here um
can you can you come on myself obviously
everybody oh yeah
he's gonna do it do his job but trey
every day vlogs man
you can't miss a date bro no you're a
big big fan shout out to fresh for the
consistency
that he's been given so he has dirt 33k
right now come on man
get the numbers up get the numbers up
man let me try
to work with blog there you go
right there so you can see how chris
does the thing behind the scenes
ally um so it's two and two two alley
you can sit right there
i think that works out
crispy doing this thing but yeah um
some blueberries blueberries blueberries
bro
i do i i suppose i swim yesterday bro
okay look
look look so i don't know why i just get
like a fake vibe
from the show like i have no doubt that
they're doing this stuff but
i don't know why i never get the vibe
that they can pull
females left and right from either of
them
i'd still treat i'd still go on their
show though high key
like i just don't get the vibe that they
like pull girls left
for the youtube okay no trey they need
blueberries yesterday
yeah you did i did bro i did
nah they taste pretty good man the small
ones taste better
they're sweeter
all right guys look at some blueberries
real quick haters gonna hate
but i should like blueberries so let me
eat some real quick
so real quick
a little bit healthier
look i'm using blueberries
yeah kind of stuff but there you go
i guess we're back about to go live real
quick so we're gonna plug this stuff and
we'll get the show going so we'll start
here what's going on youtube it is nina
i'm ready to go ahead and check me out
on youtube i do have three channels
check out my instagram nina
unrated and check out my only fans where
i get freaking nasty i cook i clean i
swallow and i'll say it
wait so why are you unready though they
got to see the booty listen
only fans there you go mine rated there
you go
all right what's up this is your girl
coley follow me on coolywork
cruellyrare.com oh my gosh no i can't do
it because i have so much different
[ __ ] websites
yo show them the gear man you gotta show
them again
by the way follow ugly merch um he's
upcoming
he's inside a gallery so go check that
out
anytime you need it cool there you go
and then thanks
hi what's up it's your girl maria i'm
from new jersey jersey
yeah jersey house um my instagram is um
underscore maria
underscore eight five six underscore
that's too many underscores i don't care
sexual stance all right cool
under dashes why do all these girls like
i don't know why i can tell in girls
foreheads
if they've already got botox because
their skin's like shiny
i maybe i'm jealous because i can't
afford it i don't know
um i don't really have to like rep
anything cuz i don't have a business but
like my instagram is
i n n a a dot xxl you are your business
there you go yeah i am my own business
there you go literally i'm ally at real
thumb sapien on ig i
am a feminine femininity coach and a
stay-at-home fiance it's worth it
there you go i love that hey what's good
i'm charlie rose the great aka ariel to
my right who grew ladies from stuff
nothing nothing that ordered you i rap
out here in miami for the past eight
years you feel me from a z
touchdown you feel me trying to hurt you
know what it is that was
quite an intro so okay we're gonna start
a little bit guys um as you can see
behind the scenes man chris the producer
gave his speech
yeah man like they don't love the law
but they're a ladies man that's a talent
man
so this is the uh control panel here
yeah guys
about starting the show um a long day
and uh yeah it's been cracking
frank castle's here yeah just uh that's
a sharp real quick guys you know what
i'm saying
we got the ninja should watch your shirt
and we got a new instagram piece that we
just made
you'll pull instagram real quick oh yeah
we just made it we need 100 followers we
can't
no on our freshman pod
what is it yeah it will first tripod
fresh fit podcast
fresh yeah fresher podcast
fresh fit podcast come on trey
no not in here right there yeah okay
let's do it go follow our new backup
official backup page
for our on instagram page because the
first one got deleted uh
it's going to be back though so don't
worry but for now follow this page we're
going to post everything here
uh in the current status but so yeah go
follow this page um it's our new backup
page
and yeah guys go support us so we're
back on instagram
so yeah um there you go trey followed
hey followers
so here you go um so yeah guys we're
gonna start in a little bit
and uh yeah it's a showtime enjoy the
show
youtube there we go
where am i
you want me to drop my pin i'm i'm in
brick
okay
what the [ __ ] i feel like i should not
be listening to this conversation
no i'm not with no one
come to me i'm about to drop my phone
right now you coming
all right baby
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
wait is that x okay
you got him all right all right want
five properties you got some [ __ ]
i want to know because i already own
poverty in jamaica i want to buy
property
okay cool we're not going to have this
debate we're not going to have this
debate like
you're the one trespassing looking
stupid on camera in 4k
with a bunch of cameras probably
trespassing if i was invited here i have
the address and i walked in with you
okay
i was looking by florida law your
invitation is officially retracted
if i wanted to i could physically grab
you and throw you out of here
no you're trespassing
i don't know why but it comes off weird
when guys argue
with the girl just call the cops dude oh
my gosh
how do we get here i'm so confused i
don't know why if someone wanted me to
leave i would just go
wait i'm not you're not gonna you're not
gonna get that energy you're just gonna
dump when the cops show up it is what it
is
we're gonna make money off your patreon
because you look stupid right now
so call 911 like literally
you're you're a clown you're going to
look stupid and you're about to be on
her youtube as well
when i want to go on the
this is my vlog okay yeah i loved it i
love it
there you go
look she's not now she's she stepped on
my foot now she's still here are you
gonna you're gonna walk out
i want you to touch me okay i'm waiting
that's not gonna happen
wow you're gonna physically put me out
right no no one's gonna
no one's gonna physically touch you
what's your name fresh and fit go ahead
put me out oh my god this [ __ ] is crazy
yeah yeah so she stepped on my foot
oh what what
oh my god what yeah
that was insane okay so now that that's
what i would do i would just call the
cops
on the police she assaulted me on camera
so yeah
get on camera yeah call the cops or get
the cops over here
so something like twice
all right yeah go send them over why is
it always the black chicks bro it's
always
more
this is crazy man it's this great
concert
what a weird night man there's always
such ratchet ass
like girls on this show um
i don't even know what to say to that
like clearly she was ratchet as how
that was the right thing that's what he
should have done he should have called
the cops
all i was saying before is i don't
understand when guys argue with these
girls
because they're clearly irrational like
you can't logic with crazy so sometimes
police best way to go but
that's what he eventually did cool on
him um
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
bring that notification bell
uh while you're at it follow my
instagram it's just probably things but
instead of the assets gotta see
and i will talk to you guys next